et là même nous cessons de jouer les
passagers ne cesse de nous regarder des
sourires de la bien d'importance c'est
un voyage qui ne sera pas de tout repos
pour sa dernière création le théâtre
alphonse daudet prend la mer et parodies
la croisière s'amuse
la série américaine diffusée en france
dans les années 80 ce sont des histoires
qui s'entremêlent
donc il ya et ses prix ces prix au dans
le répertoire théâtral aussi bien on va
retrouver les personnages de labiche les
personnages de monsieur perrichon on va
retrouver également les personnages du
malade imaginaire de molière on va
retrouver un don juan de molière on va
retrouver les personnages de anouilh et
tout ça ça va être entre mêlée est
entrecoupé de chansons de danse pour
permettre à l'orgueil parish de se
vanter de l'avoir sauvée et ainsi de
rentrer dans sa sphère une croisière de
ouf a nécessité sept mois de répétitions
sur scène 23 comédiens professionnels et
l'amateur on est encore plus investi
dans un spectacle où on a à la fois le
regard est à la fois on doit jouer ce
qui est des fois un petit peu troublant
parce que il faut bien ce qu'il faut
savoir
il faut bien doser c'est à dire que
je me suis surprise à à écouter les
autres
à voir comment il fonctionnait quand on
joue avec des professionnels quand il
nous explique quel ton prendre quelle
attitude prendre alors que e.on l'ont
tout de suite donc les plus facile de
s'identifier de reproduire ce qu'ils
font une croisière de ouf mêle théâtre
danse et chanson une production
originale à découvrir à partir du 16 mai
[Musique]
yannick ici
et